bienvenue dans cette nouvelle édition
d'en quête d'europe
dans cette émission nous irons en
espagne le plus gros producteur de gm de
l'union européenne ensuite direction
varsovie capitale de la pologne pays qui
affichent une santé économique insolente
dans une europe en crise
enfin nous irons à l'aquila trois ans
après le séisme qui a dévasté la ville
où en est la reconstruction mais d'abord
thomas raguet nous emmène en grèce où le
patrimoine foncier de l'église orthodoxe
suscite quelques polémiques
thomas quelle est la place de l'église
orthodoxe dans la société grecque alors
en grèce l'église n'est pas séparée de
l'état les grecs sont à 90% orthodoxe
ils sont très attachés à la religion
donc il est très difficile pour un
gouvernement finalement de s'attaquer à
l'église on l'a vu au début des années
2000 avec le gouvernement de
konstantinos simitis qui a décidé de
supprimer la référence à la religion sur
les cartes d'identité
avant cela on pouvait tout simplement
savoir si vous étiez juifs musulmans ou
chrétiens orthodoxes en regardant votre
carte d'identité
ça fait beaucoup de bruit le clergé
s'est élevé contre cette mesure elle a
mobilisé ses fidèles il ya eu des
manifestations dans tout le pays
finalement la réforme est passée mais le
gouvernement simitis lui a été balayée
aux élections suivantes
donc là on vous suit athènes à deux pas
du centre nous sommes dans le principal
point de distribution alimentaire de la
ville une distribution organisée par
l'église
il est 15 heures une foule compacte
d'immigrés et de grecs se pressent pour
recevoir un repas chaud s'il vous plaît
vous allez tous est servis les repas
sont distribués par des bénévoles de la
paroisse voisine phénomène à gammarth et
les matraques avons distribué un repas
par jour il ya 1300 portion les repas
sont cuisinés ni embarquer par un
traiteur qui les lives ensuite ici tout
est payé
sur les 515 points de distribution de
l'archevêché on est passé de 5000 à
10000 et depuis six mois on est à 12
mille cinq cents repas distribués par
jour cette action sociale l'église
grecque la revendique
en pleine crise économique elle lui
permet de faire face à des critiques de
plus en plus vives visant ses privilèges
et son exceptionnel patrimoine évalué à
plusieurs milliards d'euros selon
certaines sources officieuses
il reste très difficile à estimer
en grèce l'église n'est pas séparée de
l'état les religieux à l'exception des
moines sont des fonctionnaires 9000 au
total pour un budget annuel des cultes
de 350 millions d'euros dans un pays où
le produit entre prête serment sur la
bible face au clergé l'église est
intimement lié au pouvoir la
constitution grecque
il fait explicitement référence et rares
sont ceux qui osent la critiquer
l'église est bien dans une très forte
vous avez des députés qui ne sentent le
que grâce au concours de l'église son
patrimoine l'église l'a héritée de
l'occupation ottomane
les grecs pouvait alors lui léguer leurs
biens pour éviter qu'il tombe aux mains
des tur résultat elle possède de
nombreux lieux de culte 450 monastère et
surtout des milliers d'hectares de
terres à travers tout le pays
plus surprenant l'église loue des
bâtiments immeubles d'habitation villa
sur l'un de ses terrains l'école
ecclésiale d'athènes a même fait bâtir
ce complexe commercial et un parking
dont elle perçoit les rentes en clair
l'église et ses différentes entités
n'hésitent pas à investir pour faire
fructifier leurs biens une stratégie
qu'elle assume totalement il ya une
patrie - très important mais il faut
trouver les moyens pour pouvoir utiliser
cette patrimoine pour produire quelque
chose on est salarié
on touche chaque mois notre salaire on
n'a pas besoin d'avoir un intérêt par
tous les actes qu'on veut faire et tous
les l'argent tous les produits vont
rester à l'église et on va autoriser
pour l'église et qu'est ce que c'est une
église là le but signifie les peuples
bref l'église met en avant la croissance
engendrés par ces investissements et la
redistribution de l'argent ainsi gagné
ce qui est tout à fait scandaleux
c'est le traitement de l'église le point
de vue taxe paiement de taxes etc
il y à un certain nombre de privilèges
tout à fait exorbitants et en fait aucun
contrôle fiscal n'est exercée à l'égard
de
d'après la et des évêchés la position de
l'église
un sujet qui fâche surtout quand
l'opinion a pris à l'automne dernier
qu'elles seraient exemptés d'une
nouvelle taxe foncière au ministère de
l'éducation nationale dont dépendent des
cultes on tient à préciser les choses
les choses sont claires existent en ce
qui concerne ses activités en dehors de
l'adoration elle-même way la même chose
que tout le monde loue un bien
immobilier une taxe comme vous et moi
pour couper court à la polémique le
saint synode a récemment publié sa
contribution fiscale 12 millions d'euros
en 2011 une somme en nette hausse par
rapport aux années précédentes car
depuis 2010
ses revenus sont taxés à hauteur de 20%
quant à l'impact budgétaire des cultes
le message est clair pas strictement
économique capital gestion salaire n'est
rien c'est yannick est comparé à selon
la société en grèce parler de séparation
de l'église et de l'état est quasiment
tabou et les rares projets de réforme
d'envergure ont généralement été bien
vite enterré dans un pays où 90% de la
population est orthodoxe l'influente
église grecque dominera encore longtemps
la vie publique
thomas pourquoi est ce que c'est si
difficile de chiffrer le patrimoine de
l'église
alors faut savoir que l'église grecque
est très morcelé c'est dû en partie à
l'histoire grecque en fonction de la
zone géographique où l'on se trouve
l'autorité n'est pas la même donc c'est
un pouvoir beaucoup moins centralisée
que ne peut l'être d'églises catholiques
par ailleurs il ya les monastères ils
sont 450 dans tout le pays ce sont eux
les principaux propriétaires terriens et
il fonctionne de manière autonome
il ya même celui du mont athos qui est
quasiment un micro-état donc c'est très
difficile de chiffrer ce patrimoine et
donc je l'estimé et l'église at elle
toujours été exemptés d'impôts alors
elle en a payé sous l'occupation
ottomane jusqu'à l'indépendance du pays
à cette époque là le gouvernement grec a
voulu récupérer des terres et donc en
échange a exempté de taxes il ya
toujours eu des deals entre l'église et
l'état
exactement à la salle après la seconde
guerre mondiale à nouveau l'état veut
récupérer des ternes en échange l'église
aucun des immeubles dans les
centres-villes faut savoir que dans le
laps de temps elle paye à nouveau des
impôts mais les membres du clergé sont
donnés des fonctionnaires donc à chaque
fois il ya une sorte d' échanges entre
église et état
il ya quand même des exceptions il ya eu
des taxes notamment en pleine crise
dernièrement en 2010 le gouvernement
papandréou a décidé de taxer les revenus
de l'église et ça a fait augmenter sa
contribution fiscale qui est passé de 2
millions 5 en 2010 à plus de 12 millions
d'euros l'année dernière
merci thomas alors que la grèce
s'enfonce dans sa cinquième année de
récession d'autres pays de l'union
européenne affichent une santé
économique insolente
c'est le cas de la pologne une réalité
qu'il faut toutefois savoir nuancé
fabrice on parle de miracle le polonais
pour quelle raison ce miracle polonais
c'est d'abord un chiffre 4 % de
croissance l'année dernière une
croissance qui est annoncée pour cette
année encore à 3% quand le g tassement
mais quand même un chiffre qui
évidemment donne envie à beaucoup
d'autres pays européens mais c'est un
miracle qu'il faut aussi nuancé parce
que la pologne s'est beaucoup de chômage
9 % de chômage
et puis un salaire moyen qui reste très
faible autour de 800 euros
donc c'est un miracle c'est un paradoxe
un peu polonais et nous on s'est
intéressé à la vitrine la vitrine c'est
varsovie en plein boom économique des
immeubles partout je vous propose de
voir ça dans le sujet que nous sommes
allés tourner en pologne à varsovie
pendant quelques jours et la bienvenue
chez moi
à tout juste 20 ans martin a quitté sa
famille et sa campagne pour cette
résidence de la banlieue de varsovie
car depuis deux ans il étudie dans la
plus prestigieuse école de commerce du
pays
en pologne si l'on veut réussir la
capitale est un passage obligé
le miracle économique polonais serait à
ce prix oui j'ai lu beaucoup d'articles
sur ce miracle polonais c'est vrai la
situation économique évolue bien depuis
quelques années nous les polonais on
aime bien se plaindre mais on doit
admettre que notre pays est en pleine
réussite en ce moment dans le sens où
l'on est le seul pays à ne pas être
touché par la crise
plus qu'un miracle
la pologne est un eldorado partout à
varsovie les sociétés étrangères sa
fiche et embauche dans cet immeuble
l'un des premiers français à avoir cru
en ce boom économique
c'était en 2006 six ans plus tard la
société d'ingénierie informatique de
grégoire nitot emploie 1000 salariés
dans tout le pays
tout le monde vient s'implanter en
pologne est-ce qu'il ya différentes pour
deux raisons en fait tu la prends la
première c'est pour conquérir le marché
polonais marché de 40 millions
d'habitants jeunes qui consomment
deuxièmement c'est pour chercher des
solutions donc des centres
offshore onshore moindre coût que les
pays occidentaux et l'a donc la police
lui a sion polonaise est très recherchée
parce que c'est une population fortement
diplômés car l'autre atout de la pologne
c'est sa jeunesse un peu le nez sur deux
a moins de 35 ans entre 2004 et 2007 un
million choisi de chercher du travail à
l'étranger depuis la donne a changé
on recrute de nombreux polonais qui
reviennent d'allemagne d'angleterre
parce qu'ils trouvent des niveaux de
salaires très intéressant ici notamment
à varsovie
donc c'est une chance pour ces jeunes
polonais à la chambre de commerce franco
polonaise de varsovie on nuance est
question des salaires si tu peux voir
qui encore on peut contacter les postes
très qualifiés rattrapent leur retard
mais la pologne c'est avant tout une
main d'oeuvre bon marché
800 euros c'est le salaire mensuel moyen
c'est vrai qu'il reste des choses à
faire c'est vrai que chacun ait le
gouvernement essaye d'augmenter le
salaire minimum pour et on se rapproche
petit à petit peut-être pas assez
rapidement pour certains d
des salaires un peu dont j'ai fait même
limitrophes la république tchèque a
quand même des salaires plus élevés que
la pologne
donc c'est vrai que c'est un peu
l'envers du décor c'est vrai que pour
les jeunes c'est pas toujours facile de
trouver du travail pour trouver un
emploi seuls certains cursus sont une
garantie comme les formations techniques
ou celle d'ingénierie dans ces domaines
cette université de varsovie est la plus
répétée est-ce que je te prends le
rapport sur les débouchés des étudiants
merci selon ces chiffres 86 % des
étudiants trouvent un emploi dans les
six mois après leur diplôme et moins de
10% partiront à l'étranger
le résultat d'un partenariat étroit avec
les entreprises avec les nouveaux
besoins sur le marché du travail
nous avons créé de nouvelles spécialités
et nous avons ouvert de nouvelles
facultés qui réponde mieux aux attentes
des entreprises et des étudiants
et puis au sein de l'université il ya un
conseil où siègent des grandes
entreprises
cela permet de connaître les profils
qu'elle recherche
méchaal est l'un des 33 mille étudiants
de l'université de polytechnique in est
quasiment assuré de trouver un emploi à
l'issue de sa formation
mais loin de varsovie la réalité serait
plus complexe alors il attend avant de
parler de miracle
je dirais que je suis plutôt réaliste
mais avec une dose d'optimisme pour
notre avenir
je crois profondément que dans 10 ou 15
ans
la situation de la pologne sera vraiment
bien meilleure cet avenir de la pologne
dépend en partie de l'europe
sa croissance de plus de 4% est sous
perfusion de l'union et une enveloppe de
67 milliards d'euros ces dernières
années aujourd'hui le pays est face à un
défi améliorer le niveau de vie de sa
population sans perdre de son
attractivité
une équation complexe
vous le disais fabrice varsovie c'est un
peu une vitrine
quelle est la réalité en dehors de la
capitale oui le miracle polonais c'est
clairement un miracle à deux vitesses
unis à varsovie plein boom économique on
l'a vu les immeubles les investisseurs
étrangers qui sont très présents mais à
côté c'est la campagne polonaise et là
c'est une autre réalité manque
d'infrastructures un développement qui
est très très lent tout tout reste à
faire en dehors de varsovie et ce
miracle ça brille c'est aussi grâce aux
fonds européens
clairement c'est clairement un miracle
sous perfusion européenne 70 milliards
d'euros investis depuis 2007 et jusqu'en
2013 70 milliards investis
principalement pour les infrastructures
puisque la pologne ou en dehors de tout
ne serait ce qu'en en réseau routier
et puis 70 milliards au surtout investi
dans l'agriculture parce que ces
campagnes qui sont à la traîne il faut
les développer et donc l'europe a décidé
de soutenir l'agriculture polonaise qui
s'est grandement développé ça dépend des
régions mais en tout cas c'est le moyen
trouvé pour l'europe par l'europe pour
essayer de justement de booster ses
campagnes polonaise qui sont encore à la
traîne
effectivement la pologne est un des pays
qui bénéficie le plus de la politique
agricole commune mais il ya un autre qui
s'intéressent à la pologne
c'est la chine oui la chine a clairement
fait de la pologne sa tête de pont en
europe
le premier ministre chinois étaient
encore en pologne fin avril pour signer
tout simplement une ligne de crédit de
10 milliards de dollars pour mettre au
point des projets de coopération
donc la chine est très près déjà très
présente en pologne et surtout elle veut
utiliser la pologne pour rayonner dans
cette europe centrale cette europe
orientale avec un projet tout simple 100
milliards de dollars d'échangés
commerciaux et économiques d'ici à 2015
avec cette zone européenne
donc autant dire que c'est un gros enjeu
merci fabrice un autre dossier secoue
l'union européenne les ogm
si certains pays ont pris des moratoires
sur ces semences d'autres commencent à
le produire en masse c'est le cas de
l'espagne et ses bérengère d'un glace
qui nous en parle
bérengère quelle est la situation sur
les organismes génétiquement modifiés
aujourd'hui dans le monde les organismes
génétiquement modifiés ne cesse de
progresser leurs surfaces ont augmenté
de 8% en 2011 et dans ce paysage qui est
globalement favorable aux ogm
l'europe fait un peu figure d'exception
les organismes génétiquement modifiés en
europe ne représente qu'1 % des surfaces
cultivées au niveau mondial aujourd'hui
à sept pays européens qui ont émis des
clauses de sauvegarde
c'est à dire qu'elle interdit sur leur
propre sol la culture du mon 810 au
niveau légal c'est discutable donc c'est
pourquoi il ya quelques semaines l oms
ces pays ont essayé de négocier un
compromis au niveau européen
parce que en même temps de l'autre côté
de l'europe il ya six pays aujourd'hui
qu'ils cultivent du mon 810 et dans ces
pays là bien sûr c'est l'espagne qui est
un petit peu la tête de pont des ogm en
europe puisque les surfaces cultivées en
espagne représente aujourd'hui 85 % de
ce qui est cultivé au niveau européen
mais malgré sa position de leader il ya
une résistance qui s'organise donc on
vous suit en andalousie
en ce moment pour rundle c'est l'une des
périodes les plus importantes de l'année
chaque jour il inspecte ses ruches pour
que sa récolte soit la meilleure
possible
des efforts qui pourraient être réduits
à néant
depuis l'automne dernier il a beaucoup
de mal à vendre son miel
comme tout le miel espagnol celui ci est
suspecté de contenir des traces de gm
car en espagne
près du quart du maïs produit du mon810
un maïs génétiquement modifié et le maïs
aujourd'hui le maïs transgénique n'est
pas balisé il est mélangé avec le maïs
conventionnelles et il peut y avoir un
apport de pollen ogm dans la ruche sans
que l'apiculteur le sache
d'habitude
migaud elle vend toute sa production à
l'étranger en allemagne et en france
principalement mais l'an dernier
impossible d'exporter le moindre pot en
cause un jugement de la cour européenne
de justice de septembre 2011
appelés à faire bloc il interdit à la
vente tout miel ou pollen contenant des
ogm à partir du verdict de la cour de
justice personne n'a plus voulu acheter
de miel le marché est resté complètement
bloquée il a fallu attendre pendant
trois mois avant que quelqu'un accepte
d'acheter du miel espagnol y compris le
mien et au moment de l'achat on m'a payé
25 % moins cher que six mois plus tôt
l'espagne est le premier producteur
européen de miel c'est donc l'avenir de
centaines d'apiculteurs qui est en jeu
angel et ses collègues ont décidé de se
battre contre les ogm on février dernier
ils se sont rassemblés à séville la plus
grosse manifestation anti ogm que n'ait
jamais connu la ville à la tête de la
contestation mi goualich cardio élus à
la coag ce syndicat agricole proche de
la confédération paysanne dénonce l'
influence des firmes mondiales sur la
péninsule ibérique
tandis que de nombreux pays européens
renoncent aux organismes génétiquement
modifiés
ici les surfaces ogm continue de
progresser
il essaie de convaincre je pense à
travers l'espagne que la coexistence est
possible alors qu'on sait bien que que
tout cela cesse
un gros mensonge si tu fais des mauges m
d'ailleurs tu es en train d'interdire
que quelqu'un puisse faire du bio que
quelqu'un puisse faire de l'apiculture
on pense que c'est une stratégie de
monsanto et d'autres entreprises de
d'essayer à tout prix de faire augmenter
la surface
pour l'instant le seul ogm autorisé dans
le pays et le maïs mon810 un maïs
contenant un insecticide bt il est
cultivé sur près de cent mille hectares
mais personne ne sait exactement où car
en espagne
il n'existe aucune cartographie des
plantations ogm bac est ici c'est roger
nique
merci ça ne l'est pas mais on voit pas
la différence
c'est sur les bords du guadalquivir que
roanne a décidé de semer du mon 810
comme on le constate le maïs ogm et le
maïs conventionnelles ne sont pas
différencier tous les grains finiront
ensemble voilà trois ans que cet
agriculteur andalou a commencé à planter
du maïs ogm et pour lui les rendements
sont nettement meilleures l'an dernier
j'ai abandonné la culture transgénique
et la pyrale une larve qui affecte le
maïs est apparu
résultat ma production a baissé de 50%
au lieu de 160 170 tonnes par hectare je
n'ai récolté que 80 tonnes géré planter
des ogm car c'est la seule solution
contre la pyrale en espagne si le
pouvoir politique de droite comme de
gauche reste favorable aux ogm
les opposants sont de plus en plus
nombreux ainsi la puebla descazals à une
ville de 11 mille habitants sur la route
de malaga la commune s'est déclarée sans
ogm
un travail de persuasion entrepris par
le maire bendjo le processus a consisté
à convaincre les agriculteurs de la
région que les produits qui nous arrive
en ce moment et les produits qui sont
vendus à l'international sont
contre-productifs pour le futur de nos
enfants
pendant des années en espagne les ogm
ont été avant tout considéré comme une
avancée scientifique
aujourd'hui certaines associations et
syndicats commencent à mieux informer la
population
agriculteur ou pas ils sont de plus en
plus nombreux à vouloir que le pays tout
entier renonce aux cultures
génétiquement modifiées pour beaucoup
c'est l'avenir de l'agriculture
espagnole qui est en jeu
bérengère on le voit bien dans votre
reportage les apiculteurs ont l'air très
en colère par rapport aux producteurs de
gm mais ce ne sont pas les seuls oui
dans la manifestation qui a eu lieu à
séville au printemps dernier il y avait
également des producteurs de coton les
industriels continuent d'essayer
d'imposer des nouvelles cultures ogm en
espagne dernière en date le coton gm qui
a une qui a une demande de mise sur le
marché qui en attente aujourd'hui le
coton espagnol de toute façon il n'est
pas compétitif donc pour valoriser ce
coton ils sont décidés d'aller vers un
coton un peu plus spécifique pas bio
mais ils tendent vers le bio et j'espère
avoir du bio est aujourd'hui si un coton
gm qui est mis en place sur le marché
comme c'est le cas pour le maïs les deux
couteaux vont se retrouver dans les
mêmes sacs et donc tous les efforts de
ces agriculteurs seront réduits à néant
mais il était aussi question de
favoriser l'étiquetage
on voit en espagne seul étiquetage qui à
la base c'est un étiquetage ogm or
aujourd'hui en france l'association
réclamé depuis un certain temps un
étiquetage non ogm ce qui n'était pas
légale jusque là depuis le 1er juillet
dernier ça vient de changer
donc aujourd'hui on a des étiquettes non
ogm pour la viande on a nourri sans ogm
seul petit bémol ça concerne pas la
viande les animaux qui paissent dans des
prairies puisque lherm de toute façon il
n'ya pas une herbe ogm donc ils peuvent
pas bénéficier de cet étiquetage sans
ogm ce qui est un peu dommage dans la
mesure où c'est la viande la plus
naturelle qui soit merci bérengère il y
a trois ans la ville de l'aquila en
italie était dévasté par un fort séisme
à l'époque silvio berlusconi alors
président du conseil promettait une
reconstruction rapide
pourtant entre temps rien n'a vraiment
changé paul bouffard s'est rendu sur
place
paul pourquoi est ce que vous avez
décidé de retourner à l'aquila on a
voulu revenir sur l'une des plus grandes
catastrophes que l'italie n'est jamais
connu on a voulu savoir où en était la
reconstruction et savoir comment vivent
aujourd'hui trois ans après ces italiens
est ce qu'est devenu l'argent qui a été
versé aussi par l'union européenne donc
on vous suit dans la région des abruzzes
une cité médiévale dévastés comme
bombarder au coeur des abruzzes dans ses
rues vivait plus de 70000 personnes
aujourd'hui
l'aquila est une ville fantôme
3h32 du matin le 6 avril 2009
l'aquila est touchée par un tremblement
de terre de magnitude 6,3 sur l'échelle
de richter
la ville est totalement détruite 309
morts et plus de cinquante cinq mille
personnes évacuées à quelques kilomètres
du centre ville
l'urgence a fait pousser ses résidences
champignons trois ans après vingt-sept
mille victimes ne sont pas rentrées chez
elles
les sinistrés sont hébergées dans ces
maisons en bois
juliano et sa femme ont tout perdu
aujourd'hui ils vivent au milieu de
nulle part
rien ici pas de magasin il faut aller
loin
au milieu de ça il n'y a rien il ya que
nous et il me demande si à des magasins
et n'ont donc il n'y a rien j'en avais
il ferait du bon business
mariani ce policier à la retraite compte
chaque jour loin de chez lui
je suis ici depuis 23 février 2010 ça
fait deux ans et trois mois
à 78 ans juliano se sont coupés du monde
abandonné des autorités pourtant ils
espèrent toujours reconstruire sa maison
et sa vie on attend de rentrer chez nous
ça sera un soulagement psychologique
pour voir où tu as été baptisé marié où
tu as eu des enfants ont tué devenu
grand père c'est la chose la plus
importante
toute une vie si tu es un toit sur la
tête mais ça s'arrête là
la vie d'avant elle n'existe plus tu ne
pourras plus la voir trois années se
sont écoulées depuis la catastrophe
le coeur historique en ruine et
inhabitables dans cette zone rouge
surveillé par l'armée
personne ne peut circuler au détour
d'une ruelle abandonné un irréductible
fausto corti il préside l'association de
sauvegarde du patrimoine local et pour
lui pas question de laisser tomber sa
cité 100 mégas ça c'est ma maison c'est
le jardin de chez moi
dans sa maison la reconstruction n'a pas
commencé la vaisselle du soir du séisme
est encore dans l'évier
au lendemain du drame la commission
européenne verse une aide de près de 500
millions d'euros à l'état italien
une aide qui n'a pas servi à la
reconstruction
le problème principal aujourd'hui c'est
que l'argent reste dans les caisses de
l'état
à cause de la bureaucratie l'italienne
qui bloque la reconstruction
surtout ici dans le centre historique
trois ans après le tremblement de terre
on est encore au stade des projets à
l'époque dans l'urgence le gouvernement
berlusconi sécurisé les bâtiments
endommagés opération trop coûteuse pour
les architectes et urbanistes la mairie
de la queen à l'administration générale
a dépensé 400 millions d'euros dans le
processus de cette médiation
elles ont employé des milliers
d'ouvriers des centaines d'ingénieurs
sans même savoir s'il était possible de
sauver tel ou tel bâtiment ou s'il
fallait des frais aujourd'hui les
autorités sont encore dans l'urgence et
se contente de financer l'aide aux
victimes de l'argent gaspillé selon
fausto corti plus la reconstruction
durera longtemps plus l'argent partira
dans l'assistance d'urgence entre
personnes tous les habitants de l'aquila
sont assistés reçoivent de l'argent
public
mais cet argent devrait plutôt servir à
reconstruire au final plus on est
assistée - et durera de fonds pour
sauver la vie le 18 mai dernier
élections municipales le maire massimo
cialente et est reconduit lors d'une
conférence de presse il présente son
plan de réhabilitation mais reste un
problème
un homme un opposant au maire le
commissaire du gouvernement pour la
reconstruction
depuis la nomination de ce proche de
silvio berlusconi
au lendemain du séisme les fonds
n'arrivent plus aucun chantier n'a vu le
jour
le gouvernement dit qu'il ya de l'argent
continue de le dire
alors si c'est vrai donnez-nous les
ressources pour avancer
s'il n'y a rien il faut nous le dire
c'est un acte de responsabilité de le
dire
pourtant malgré le sentiment d'abandon
les habitants petit à petit se
réapproprie les ruines il y à quelques
lieux de vie avec des commerçants qui se
réinstallent qui ont repris leurs
activités
je les appelle les pionniers mais au
final c'est vrai que la ville a du mal à
en face à la lenteur des autorités
italiennes
la municipalité de l'aquila veut devenir
capitale européenne de la culture en
une dernière chance pour espérer un
sursaut et la reconstruction
qu'est ce qui vous a marqué durant ce
reportage et bien en fait j'ai vraiment
eu l'impression d'être au coeur d'une
ville fantôme dans les rues on croise
personne à part quelques militaires et
des agents de la municipalité qui
patrouillent pour surveiller la zone car
elle est encore très dangereuse elle
n'est pas accessible à les fermer le
centre ville est complètement fermé
alors en périphérie il ya quelques
magasins qui rouvrent petit à petit
chose étonnante aussi je me suis
retrouvé devant un bar tabac est figé
dans le temps même les bulletin de loto
gagnant sont restés par terre telle
qu'elle est qu'on voit sur ces images là
exactement
donc j'ai vraiment eu l'impression
d'être au coeur d'un pompéi bis mais
concrètement est ce qu'on peut espérer
un jour voir l'aquila reconstruite
concrètement l'italie est confrontée à
la crise de la dette qui secoue toute
l'europe à la peu de marge de manoeuvre
donc le gouvernement essaie de lever des
fonds récemment ils ont augmenté la taxe
sur l'essence
ça pourrait lever 500 millions d'euros
en 2013 sinon il ya d'autres mesures un
peu plus médiatique cette fois ci
l'équipe nationale de football italienne
la squadra azzurra exactement finaliste
à l'euro 2012 a décidé de reverser la
totalité de ses primes pour venir en
aide aux victimes dernier levier
peut-être pour le maire de l'aquila
massimo cialente et qui vient d'être
réélu et gardent en tête un rêve un peu
être un peu fou c'est de faire de sa
ville la capitale européenne de la
culture en 2019
c'est peut-être la dernière chance de
sauver la couleur merci toile voilà
c'est la fin de cette émission nous on
se retrouve très vite sur public sénat
et tous les jours sur publicsenat.fr